all right let's give you I actually had
some bad news
slightly might be wondering why there's
a little delay here we actually didn't
get a stop
but we did get this down
why are we here today we are here today
to be a you know child thinking and
overly confuse I don't believe in the
power of the law but let me tell you
something
there was another doubted it by the name
of spooning do you know spooning a long
time ago spooning had a misfortune of
breaking his foot that's right he broke
his foot he was doing a Ronald McDonald
charity and he broke his foot ironically
tripping on a heavy let me tell you he
came up to me and he said to heal this
that's it that's a community that's it
come here put it I'm in spooning but I
love the fact you named after my
favorite sexual position and I said
I want his penis he has studied when to
attack them because him hallelujah now
everybody bow your heads and pray bow
your head
lord please grab that a be funny today
that just kind of funny not just sort of
funny really fine and lord please look
after those who do not have homes
tonight like this poor unfortunate bum I
met outside the name of Chester for
unfortunately human being he likely to
be Avatar God have mercy on God have
mercy on the Academy as well nominate an
avatar district neither not Star Trek
what the fuck
Lord Lord please look after the
nostalgia critic he speaks in strange
tongues that poor boy must know that
mattress mattress that is naturally wood
but what do you expect with a Yukon
Education anja skin so why are we here
today we are here to feed some people
now you do young woman you can see
without those glasses you do you believe
that you can see math and glasses do you
believe that you can see God let him/her
see let's see let's see let's see them
glasses
can you see crystal clear
when you try these up try these out here
that works
now young young maid I can cure your
love your redhead in this we can make
you a natural pretty sure you but you
have to have faith in this young woman
not let's try this dare you ignore an
audience do you believe that she can do
it the Graduate star you've gotta get
some sort of paradigm product you got
using the shower
and you will be blue
what does she look like she you know
isn't that not even you just that how
could this turn me on
I imagine anyone would ever be the
sexiest thing in the world you come out
do the trick now I have a feeling
because you see I like John Edwards but
for real I have a sense that you are
going there am i right
you say we are gonna make not Napoli
don't one do not lie to me if you in
fact not going death please let me know
that are you doing this now are you sure
that because happened
young man now young man what have you
you come here to be healed
what is your problem he is a mute
speaking can you talk in this room to be
blades man have let me whisper content
with the lower right now did you want to
help me I want you
you are
you won't sad but the fact that that gap
is is do not be here tonight but I'm
gonna make it up to you how would you
all like to be
god sakes just cameraman
we believe in transformations and I
believe that if you believe in I believe
that you believe we can believe together
and we can get that down the glasses
damn right now I don't want to show you
this transformation since is a very ugly
ordeal so I'll go in the back I'll get a
transform and by what I said hallelujah
are we ought to say hi Amelia and I bet
you I can bet you the Backhouse glass is
gonna be here right now
I think when I say hallelujah
the glasses will be here I think let's
try this one more time but not believe
it you better fucking believe this trap
is again
you